We still got him Tye
Oh there he is on top. Keep reeling.
Keep reeling.
I see him I see him
I'll turn the handle.
You pull you pull
I see him
We gotta pull him
away from this trap
He’s literally right by this trap
What is going on here?
So the line must of
came out of the one trap that we were in,
and it just swam by that one.
Okay, we're going back us out of here.
Well, he's right here. He's
right here. He's right here. Swivel.
Oh, God. He's swimming at the boat.
Easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy, easy.
I got the swivel
He's getting out of here.
Oh, gosh.
We got motto back. We’ve been
working this fish really hard.
We've had to untangle them out of several
lots of traps,
but we're still on the line here.
We’re tightening up the leash.
So we’re only a couple of feet away.
But there's so much gear.
We're not in a pumpkin patch.
We're on a sour patch.
We're not in a cabbage patch.
We're in a lobster patch.
Oh there he is!
Go over there.
There he is.
Get over there.
He’s huge.
Coming this way, Tyler
This close was like 35, 40 feet away,
This fish aint ready to quit
lot of life.
still in him and he's big.
I mean this thing's big.
600-700 pounds
Got a really good
look at this fish big sickle fins.
This is a big one.
This line's already
been compromised quicker.
We can get this fish come up quicker.
Tyler can put a dart in it.
He's straight up and down at this point,
but he's doing dramatic turns.
He's going up, down,
all around into the patch, out of the patch
back, drag off,
doing good, just battling this fish.
He doesn't want to give up.
This is a tough fight.
Oh, my God.
There he is.
He’s a behemoth merm!
It’s a behemoth!
And there are a lot of obstacles here.
There's just lobster gear everywhere.
It's just driving us crazy.
It's total pandemonium.
There he is. Huge color coming up
Easy.
Coming around he go back at you.
Big color.
Reel reel reel reel reel reel
reel reel reel
He's big. He's huge, Merm.
He's really big. He's
doing a nice big pinwheel.
We just need him to do
one more hit some get some
Here he is
Whoo!
he's a biggie.
I drilled him I drilled him.
You got him Tyler
I got him. He's big. It's huge.
We’re looking at 6 7 hundered pounder.
This is what
Oh my God
This is what the fights goats
This is what makes the goat right here
Tail rope!
Big fish!
Really big fish right in our back yard.
Let me get the tail rope on him.
Yes!  Whoo!
He’s huge!
We got a big one!
We got a jumbo!
Aahh! Thanks Merm!
Nothing about this fish fight was easy.
We managed to get through this hole, catch
a lobster trap.
By far the biggest fish in the season
right here to the true GOATS right here.
We don't just catch baby tunas,
we catch them everywhere.
Another new spot for us this season!
Big boy coming on board.
Big boat big fish.
Big boy.
That's a big look at how big this fish is.
Oh, my God.
Wow, what a beefs.
It’s long it’s wide.
What a huge fish.
Who's going to be a big payday!
Couldn't get any of these down there.
Chatham.